okay it's now 11 o'clock
it's all over the reading
first thing I would like to do is
congratulate representative Wallner who
has a new grandchild
you want to tell us about him
addressing us
sure good morning members of the
committee
um
my name is Michael Kane I'm the
legislative budget assistant I'll be two
seconds as you know Steve Smith in our
office or out of director retired
um in the middle of July so on August
1st with the approval of the chair of
fiscal committee representative Weiler
who we have promoted Christine young as
a new auto director Christine's been
with her office 29 plus years in the
financial division she's well liked by
everyone in our office as well as the
agencies he's worked with so I just want
to introduce you to Christine I didn't
want to send a group email I know you
get a lot of emails so I thought I'd do
it in person and I'll just leave it at
that thank you is she here
hi Christine welcome
we look forward to working with you more
closely
great thanks Mike
first on our agenda
because we have a quorum and um today we
have representative Edwards
appointed for today to replace
representative Earth
who could not be here
um
minutes of okay but I would say
so
moved by Senator Lang second and by
representative why are the minutes of
April uh
discussion representative Weber
working oh they aren't working now sorry
I'm
just operator malfunctioned apparently
um
the vote on the chair it says on a
motion by representative Earth seconded
by Senator Whitley that Senator
Rosenwald be elected chair it did not
note that there was a vote on that and I
believe there was so
um you know motion adopted following
that sentence I think would be helpful
thank you
okay
um any other Corrections
amendments discussion
can we do a show of hands
all in favor of it adopting the
imminence with that one change
okay
abstain one abstention
number two is we need a vice chair
I would nominate representative Jerry
Griffin
representative Weiler has nominated
representative Griffin in that seconded
by Senator Lang
discussion
he's an active member of the finance
committee and the CPA
is he willing
he's willing
any
other nominations
in that case we'll cast one vote for
representative Griffin congratulations
okay
um now number three is status of ongoing
performance audits
Jay and Christine
welcome
does the committee have questions
I guess not
um could he come sit at the table and
quit case their questions
does anyone in the committee have
questions about the scope statement
Senator Whitley
good morning for the record my name is
John clinch I'm a senior audit uh
Professor uh
senior audit manager with the office of
legislative budget assistant
um I can give you a summary of the of
the scope statement if you'd like
um
according to RSA 354a colon 1 that
prohibits discrimination
the commission of Human Rights was
founded to eliminate and prevent
discrimination in employment in places
public accommodation and in housing
accommodations
the commission is tasked with receiving
investigating and making findings upon
completion I'm sorry upon complaints
alleging violations of discrimination
laws
um the commission consists of seven
voting members appointed by the governor
and consent with the consent of uh
executive Council and as of May 2023 the
commission staff consisted of an
executive director assistant director
fire five
investigators intake coordinator a
paralegal and a secretary
uh what gave rise to this audit was uh
the Judiciary commit committee found
that there was a large backlog of cases
as of June 8 2023 there's a back load of
260 cases with the oldest case filed in
January of 2022
a case is considered to be in the
backlog if a complaint had been received
but not assigned to an investigator
um
see the previous lpaoc proposed the
following scope statement and it was
presented to the fiscal committee
um
and that is is the commission for human
rights efficiently and effectively
enforcing laws against discrimination
when receiving investigating and making
findings on the complaints
um fiscal committee approved that scope
statement and we present it here today
for your consideration to address the
question we reviewed relevant laws and
statutes we interviewed commission
members
um got some perspectives of stakeholders
and we will plan to review case files
and survey complainants and respondents
to the surveys
the audit period will be State fiscal
year 2020-23 and we anticipate the audit
will be completed in March of 2024.
thank you I'd be happy to take any
questions
representative Weber
just out of curiosity I understand that
the definition of backlog is simply the
cases that have not yet been assigned to
an investigator
do you happen to know off the top of
your head how many cases are actually in
the pipeline that have not that have
been started but have not come to
conclusion yet do we know that
I'm sorry I don't have that information
okay
just
thank you madam chair so one of the
things I think we'd be looking for is
how can we reduce the backlog and the
time a year is seems very excessive and
I know you'll look at other states and
and see what they have and perhaps the
federal government and see if if we're
worse than them better than them they
might all have a big backlog but if if
the pro if the problem is we don't have
enough people then that's something we
would like to read about and maybe do
something about to correct because I
think a year and a 200 something backlog
is excessive thank you
representative
do you have a sense of
how long will it take to bring on board
those
four new investigators we're basically
doubling the size of the investigative
team
but it's going to be a while right right
well following up on representative
Wyler's question is there some National
Standard of caseload that these four
investigators
might allow us to get to
representative of Edwards
uh uh thank you I as I recall uh the way
they are set up and the way they work
their cases is they make a case
determination and I forget what the
categories are but let's just say for
this that the categories range from uh
being validated and uh and action needs
to be taken to
um something that didn't indicate to
have Merit and so uh I would be curious
uh if the audit would be looking also at
over the course of time
or the the nature of the cases as
they're being adjudicated and and to see
if there's any kind of a correlation
between the amount of time it's taking
to get cases done relative to whether or
not you know whether they have Merit or
not and uh just to see if if uh we're
we're backlogging our system with
um not frivolous but uh cases that may
not have should not have been brought
but so
there we go uh one of the difficulties
we have is the commission doesn't have a
database of cases so we're going to have
to go in and use look at file reviews
by hand
they don't have anything automated that
we can get statistics out of so that
limits how long we can look back into
the past we anticipate we'll be able to
describe that for one of the fiscal
years probably fiscal State fiscal year
23 but to go further back than that
would be difficult and I think the
categories you're looking for were
um
probable cause and no probable cause
that's one of the intermediary decisions
that the commission makes
you're welcome
any other questions Senator Whitley
thank you madam chair so on that on that
same note it's it's actually surprising
to hear that they don't have a database
to sort of track outcomes
um and so perhaps that could be an area
that you look at in terms of comparison
to other states and certainly I see that
as impacting their efficiency if they're
not sort of tracking their management
processes thank you
representative Wyler thank you madam
chair so another thing that occurs to me
without a database you might have the
same person bringing in complaints every
other year about the same sort of thing
and you know so it becomes kind of just
the game if you will trying to get some
other additional thing they want but
especially if they're going from job to
job and become a chronic complainer I
think that ought to be pointed out
anyway we may encounter that thank you
anyone else represented Senator Lane
I moved to approve the scope of work
and it by representative Weber any
further discussion
can we do this by a show of hands
okay
all right number of item number four is
the table suspended and potential audit
topics
Mr Henry
and miss you
okay
with this we'll start with the Bureau of
elderly and Adult Services that audit
was suspended in November 2021 due to
appending Legal proceeding and uh
there's no update on that
next is the public access to bodies of
water
audit topic that was tabled it was
decided not to move forward with that
audit as there might be another
committee responsible for that topic so
that was tabled
then we have the Secretary of State's
archives and Records
this one it was tabled because it was
unclear if the LBA had the authority and
statute to conduct a performance audit
here the LBA audit division statute RSA
14 colon 31a section d
excludes constitutional officers in the
execution of their constitutional duties
from a performance audit
we asked Senate research for the
definition of of constitutional officers
and constitutional duties and to
identify which duties if any are
possibly auditable
according to Senate research which was
provided in your handouts there
is no definition of constitutional
officers or constitutional duties in the
New Hampshire statutes
so without those definitions it Still
Remains unclear if we have the authority
to perform this audit
Senator Whitley
there we go I wanted to address that
issue I took a look at that memo and I
think it is true that the statute is the
statute is ambiguous as to whether
there's there's coverage but I do think
there's a strong argument to be made
that uh the legislature does have
authority to review the office I think
it's correct that the Secretary of
State's office or the officer is created
by the Constitution but all of their
duties are not their Duty there's no
Duty defined in our constitution all of
the duties are defined in State Statute
which the legislature
you know of course is responsible for
and I think if you look at there was
some Supreme Court cases that that they
that Senate resource Senate research
identified and it's pretty clear that
um that part uh is very clear that the
Secretary of State's Judy shall be those
of both legislative branch as well as
the executive executive branch so I
think there's a very strong argument
that even though the actual person
secretary of state is a constitutional
officer the office itself and the duties
are stack are statutory by nature and
therefore we do have authority to
audit
representative Wyler well I think the
audit function is so important that we
ought to change the law if anybody on
this committee would like to
proceed with a suggested legislation I
would be happy to co-sponsor because we
a few years ago when most of us were
still here we tried to audit the Supreme
Court or the court system
that was a two-year battle it should not
have been
it should be clear that wherever we send
money we should be able to audit them
and so when someone says oh no you don't
have the authority I'm thinking all
right we're going to give ourselves The
Authority because the audit is too
important they'll let somebody Escape
thank you representative Weber
thank you madam chair I I think my
position is uh doesn't go quite as far
as representative Weiler's but I I do
share his sentiment about we need to
have accountability I think I perceive a
difference between the Secretary of
State's office which is as Senator
Whitley says partially legislative and
partially executive in nature it is not
a separate branch of government the
Judiciary is a separate branch and I
think
my suggestion and I I will say that when
you put up your hand I had just written
the word need filing question mark
but I wonder if we could perhaps start
with the smaller bite of the Apple
and get that taken care of and then and
then think about a broader application
but I would be more than glad to talk to
you about that if if you would care to
do that
when it gets when it gets
my attitude like representative
weilhurst is we
fund them
program by program line by line it's
very different from so the motion is to
remove
potential audit topic of the Secretary
of State archives and Records authored
Hill motion by Senate
all in favor I'm gonna just put one
wrinkle into this uh topic
um so it's the Constitutional officer
and I think we'd probably agree the
secretary of state is a constitutional
officer and then the Constitutional Duty
that's where we sort of go which which
of those and
um with the Secretary of State uh in the
Constitution Article 68 talks about the
records of the state shall be kept in
the office of the secretary
I mean it says this duty of the
secretary so I don't know if that's I
mean Archives of the records I mean as
far if someone was going to say that's
one place we shouldn't go
because that seems like the strongest
case of the Constitution is calling it a
duty
again I'm not a lawyer I'm just throwing
it out to you I think if probably better
is if our statute was clarified
would probably is the real fix
but I already saved five CE
is the vital records
statute
and it's given by
us to this Secretary of State's office
rap bad words
thank you madam chair
um just just a thought on this is that
to the extent that there are gel car
rules that govern the record-keeping I
would think those would be auditable and
I would go further and say to the extent
that the Secretary of State's office has
developed standard operating procedures
or protocols on how they say they want
to
administer their records I would think
that those would be auditable without
causing a constitutional issue
foreign
motion from Senator link
sure
move to approve the scope of work
okay so I think the motion is to
continue and audit
by Senator Lang seconded by Senator
Pearl further discussion remember while
if a legislation is filed in September
which will come up in January
at what time span are you going to be
doing this
it depends how many times
it also depends if you have a priority
if you want something done okay before
something else
I do have the freedom accounts and then
we'll have to start sometime after I
think October this year so you know we
do have yeah we'd like to have a list of
audits to do and then we can also look
at who we have ready to do the audits
how many people we have so but if you
have something you want done
well if if you feel more confident if we
have legislation that says describes
that these Duties are you know then when
you go ahead there can't be that
roadblock so if if you're not starting
till February or March
or April right then hopefully the
legislation will be in place
representative Weber
I think the issue here is either we have
the authority to do it now
or it is a constitutional Duty and the
only way we're going to get it to stop
being a constitutional duty is by
amending the Constitution
so I think we need to think about that
um
I my vote would be to go ahead and try
it and see where we get
um uh but
if
I mean you know there could be a court
case in the the justices could say this
is not this is a constitutional Duty in
which case the only remedy
is amending the Constitution it is not
the Constitution cannot be overridden by
a statute
and that's black letter law uh so I
disagree representative okay did you
have your microphone on
I had it on
is there a further discussion we have a
motion to proceed within audit that's
already
right in the pipeline and it's just
waiting for a determination of who may
be but but the law what you said was
effective October these changes in play
and get an opportunity for them to kind
of work through it and see how they're
gonna respond
apparently I spoke too long
the department was undergoing a
transition and had some turnover in
their office the back of the table if
not I'm sorry under the table a little
about it that I'm wondering you know how
many contracts how many different
agencies and so on how many different
agencies and so on and so forth the
piece you have yes generally
turn me off again on us answers
virtually all of my questions and so
forth the piece you have yes Senator
away
turn me off again you know out of Public
Health for a public awareness campaign
or if it is a contract with some of our
homeless and housing providers those
will fall under our I.T related
contracts as well would also be captured
within that category and and that's to
stand so I believe in 2021 we gave you a
significance and is doing an absolutely
fantastic job
based on on those needs has you know
solved those issues and whether we still
see this problem an amount of resources
towards improving that process then
we've continued to measure the time that
it takes to develop an RFP to get to
contract we implemented a lean metrics
around time to do contracts and I know
it's but but you're silent on that and I
think that's been one of your major
sales points is what other sort of needs
might you anticipate of audit would find
reduce time upon the way the contract's
been written and the way the contract
staff been the for the program staff who
are standified and are working on now
are in the Commissioners finding the
goals of the contract elf earlier this
year so I think what Roberts identified
is that we want to work beating those
goals so that's another area we're
working on
thank you
Senator Whitley
I think based on that that's that was
very helpful understanding how your
office is uh interplaying with the
Contracting Office maybe this is
something much more complex so
um you know it's not a it's not a
one-size-fits-all process and and
figuring out
um you know I think starting by taking
the obvious low-hanging fruit of if we
have things that are being
uh generated online typed scanned
re-re-typed re-entered into a
spreadsheet you know surely we can get
to the point where somehow we can
eliminate all of those steps and and I'm
glad you're looking at it thank you
representative
yeah some of us are hoping to make a
meeting okay
um next
BDS PDS
um
just like I think Mr Henry can arrange
this to happen in February but if he at
least he hasn't he's also looking to us
for a list of what he wants to move on
next so I would rather have it on his
list with that timing recommended thank
you
representative
Weber and
and I respectfully disagree I think it's
too soon to put it on because I don't
think we have a clear idea of what
exactly it is we want to look at
um and and I would be happier keeping it
on the table and addressing it again at
the next meeting when we have a little
more idea
when what's going on it seems to me that
we have already
a certain amount of stuff in the
pipeline you probably need more
but I think you know perhaps having
another meeting in the not too distant
future
um in in in the fall when we have more
of our members around and and thinking
about these things uh to see if we can
generate more of a list but it sounds to
me that you actually have a fair amount
on your plate
[Music]
right
now right in that tummy
not going to be finished until next year
so you you have a lot to be going on
with with my sense
Senator Lang
thank you I also think we just leave
this as a potential audit topic for now
and mainly the reason being is I'm a
little concerned we're talking about all
the changes they're making and and
audits are retrospective they look
backwards and yet they're going to be
looking at something that's no longer
actually happening because we've made a
whole bunch of changes so I'm a little
concerned about doing an audit now it's
just a waste of State effort and we
should probably keep it in our mind but
take a look at their progress on what
their changes are
I agree and I think we should see what
the effect of the Medicaid rate
increases are because maybe some of
those
consumer complaints will be resolved
by a better Workforce I mean a more
robust Workforce Senator Whitley
yeah not only uh I would agree not only
the increases but we also have another
bill to sort of Tide over our providers
in the DD system or our families in the
DD system and while this change is going
on we're allowing them to raise their
budgets and so I think some of those
um
so I think in that meantime that's going
to help in terms of new topics you know
representative Weber just mentioned the
incident where two of our children were
placed in a very inappropriate
non-therapeutic uh facility in Tennessee
and what comes to mind to me in that
issue is this sort of interplay between
dcif and children's Behavioral Health
they work together a lot now
um but they are very separate agencies
and they often they are dealing with the
same children and as we're building the
children's Behavioral Health System
um the whole idea is that you know we'll
have less families that are involved
with dcyf but but right now we have a
lot in both we have a lot of families in
both systems and a lot of children that
are in both systems and so I mean I
think it is pretty problematic that any
child from New Hampshire did end up in
this facility has you know um
it it's not it you know regardless of
whether they were placed by dcaf or
children's Behavioral Health I think
exploring how that happened is important
um but I think it's a larger question of
how these systems fit together and
whether there's a need for more system
integration with our children's health
system
um so that's something that I would be
really interested in learning more about
and also accompanied with that is that
folks on the finance committee know very
well that the children's Behavioral
Health budget is very high and it's high
because we are at this point we're in
the middle of system change and also we
are seeing more children in the Medicaid
system because uh what I understand from
the children's Behavioral Health Bureau
is that private insurance is not
covering what is necessary so they're
pushing these high knee children into
the Medicaid system that's another issue
that I would be very interested in in
seeing whether you know the
dramatic increase of children in that
system is happening because our private
insurance aren't doing what they need to
do
Senator Lang
so I guess giving all this conversation
on these last two items I guess what I'd
be looking for is a given all a
conversation what's the scope of work
look like what are we actually looking
to do here and and and maybe develop a
scope of work that we can vote on and
and look at for a future audit but I
think everyone agrees that right now
it's probably not the time while they're
making all these changes
you mean on
the Bureau of Developmental services or
on dcyf versus
Behavioral Health
thank you the last two items we just
discussed the contract management piece
as well as the behavioral health right I
think we've both just we've we've we've
had a conversation about I think what's
what a scope of work might look like to
make potent to look at and to see what
we get for corrective actions but I
think we've also discussed and said that
neither one of them are ready for prime
time right now and so having a scope of
work to look at exactly what we're going
to be auditing and what we're going to
be looking for that performance audit
similar to what we just saw for the
human rights scope of work we voted on
um if we can see that that would be
helpful now it's moving forward and give
us time for for them to adapt that scope
of work for for our discussion
representative Weber
well now I have two things if I might um
the first before I forget it was in
response to Senator Whitley and while I
am as interested as she is in the
explosion of
Developmental services that sounds to me
more like a study committee than a
performance audit because you're talking
about what's happening with Private
Industry so
um that that might be a way of dealing
with that particular issue
um
I think we have a procedural issue with
Senator Lang's suggestion because we we
vote the audit and then the scope
statement is created so and and I think
the scope statement isn't created until
after the audit has also gone to fiscal
is that not correct doesn't the audit
have to be approved not only by us but
by fiscal before you start with a scope
statement yes that's right so we can't
just say oh please please scope
something that that that's a procedure
that's
I think it's our job to narrow down a
little more what we want people to look
at uh before and and when we have
something that's a little more specific
then we can go forward with it but I
think I think for me the comment about
audits are backward looking and when we
have a system in transition taking a
backward look at what we were doing
wrong before we did something different
isn't very helpful what we need to do is
wait and find out if what we're doing
differently is effective or not
representative Edwards I'll I'll keep it
short because we do have noon upon us
but
um just on specifically on the housing
practices subparagraph two here I I
think this one's a little bit more
cooked than the other ones because as I
understand what this one wants to be is
a review of the demands for housing
situations within BDS and the available
stock that we have in state and when we
don't have available stock and state
we're out placing people in other states
at a tremendously High expense and so so
what I think that performance audit
would want to look at is whether or not
we're making a good business decision on
our investment levels of housing stock
for BDS
due to the negative costs of having to
refer people out of state that that's
what I think that performance Otto wants
to be predominantly
representative Weber and then Senator
Whitley
and again that sounds an awful lot like
of study committee to me more than a
performance audit
Senator Whitley
and I and I
um I believe we might be conflating two
issues I think the people that are going
out of the state are children in the
dcyf behavioral health system not adults
with disabilities or children with
disabilities I'm not aware of
um
adults or children with disabilities
being sent out of state
well I think there are
there are
perhaps if there's a dual diagnosis but
you know our DD system is much more
um
were decades in advance in terms of the
provision of community-based services
and so we just don't see a lot of those
folks being pushed out of state where
where in the children's system we have a
lot of children being placed out of
state I don't know
okay well
the house has to go to another meeting
so we're gonna have to wrap this up
um I think that the next meeting we'll
talk more about what we could do with
BDS and I I was just thrown out throw
out one other idea just for everyone to
think about as a potential topic and
that is the doorways
which we've had for seven eight years 50
plus million dollars
and we've never taken a look at how
effective they are
so
just to think about
any final thoughts could could we ask
for that to be put on the list so that
those of us who allow our brains to
empty during the summer are reminded of
it because I think that that's a very
uh good suggestion also
anything further than if not
is there any other business
okay the next meeting will be it's the
call of the chair based on Mr Henry